Beetlejuice.
Beetle…popcorn?!
Tim Burton had a great time in the Addams
Family world, and you probably missed this
sneaky Beetlejuice Easter egg.
Netflix's runaway success, "Wednesday," has
a lot of secrets.
Based on the Addams Family daughter of the
same name, played by Jenna Ortega, "Wednesday"
places the iconic character into Nevermore
Academy, a school that holds a special place
in the history of the spooky family on account
of Gomez and Morticia having met there.
Of course, one of the best people to bring
this new "Wednesday" show to the small silver
screen is the legendary Tim Burton.
Made famous for his endeavors like "Edward
Scissorhands," "Batman," and "Beetlejuice,"
Burton has a rather distinct style that is
almost immediately apparent to anybody who
has had any previous experiences with the
director.
"Wait'll they get a load of me."
Speaking with Empire, Tim Burton spoke about
what inspired him to take on "Wednesday" and explained,
Tim Burton and the Addams Family is definitely
an interesting combination.
And considering the status of Burton's works
in pop culture, it's no surprise that "Wednesday"
is filled to the brim with clever callbacks
and nods to his other movies.
Throughout "Wednesday," there are tons of
Easter eggs inspired by Tim Burton's other
famous works, which was very intentional.
Production designer Mark Scruton delighted
in filling scenes with homages to Burton's
body of work.
One particular location in "Wednesday" that's
absolutely adorned with Burton references
is the Weathervanes coffee shop that many
Nevermore Academy students frequent.
If you pay close attention, you can see that
the weathervanes channel the essence of two
Burton movies — one is inspired by the Headless
Horseman from "Sleepy Hollow," and one emulates
the hat from "Charlie and the Chocolate Factory."
However, these two examples were far from
the only Easter eggs, and there were several
that were explicitly designed to reference
previous "Addams Family" shows and movies,
like Pilgrim World and the archery scene,
which are nods to Camp Chippewa in "Addams
Family Values" and Wednesday's well-known
affinity for archery.
"It's an American bald eagle."
"But aren't they extinct?"
"They are now."
And the secret way into Nevermore Academy's
secret society consists of the two finger
snaps made popular by the "Addams Family"
theme song.
Of course, one cannot put Burton-based Easter
eggs in "Wednesday" without some involving
the "Ghost with the Most."
Released in 1988, "Beetlejuice" tells the
story of a recently deceased couple, played
by Alec Baldwin and Geena Davis, who has to
come to terms with their status as ghosts
and the family that moves into their house.
Seeking to restore their former peace and
ownership of their home, the previously mentioned
couple conjures up a bio-exorcist known as
Beetlejuice.
Considering the lasting popularity of "Beetlejuice"
among Tim Burton's fans, it makes perfect
sense as to why there are multiple "Beetlejuice"
references in "Wednesday."
"You bunch'a losers.
You're working with a professional here."
Probably the easiest of these references is
the shrunken head that resembles the big game
hunter in the afterlife waiting room from
"Beetlejuice" upon the desk of Principal Weems.
However, there is a more subtle reference
in "Wednesday" that emulates the famous white
and black striped suit made popular by Beetlejuice.
In Episode 7, titled "If You Don't Woe Me
by Now," Wednesday and Tyler watch the supposed
horror movie "Legally Blonde" while eating
popcorn at Crackstone's Crypt.
However, eagle-eyed viewers or those with
their brightness settings turned up may notice
that the popcorn bag has the same color scheme
and look as Beetlejuice's typical suit, which
was definitely intentional.
Luckily for Wednesday and Tyler, they weren't
immediately compelled to sing "Day-O!," though
this is still a great Easter egg for longtime
fans of Burton.
"Yeah."